mind your decisions i'm presh tallwalker
in a square with a side length of one
construct two quarter circles and then
inscribe a circle between the quarter
circles
the challenge is to solve for the
circle's radius i thank pradeep hubbar
for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
we'll get started by drawing lines
between the corner of the square and the
tangent point on the inscribed circle
the first thing we'll do is we'll prove
that this intersection point o is the
center of the circle
we'll get started by considering one
quarter circle
consider the tangent point and the
tangent line
the perpendicular to this tangent line
will pass through the center of the
quarter circle point a
and it will pass through the center of
the inscribed circle o
however we don't know the exact location
of
o now let's consider the other quarter
circle
we'll do a similar construction we have
the tangent line and then the
perpendicular to the tangent line
this will pass through the center of the
quarter circle which is the corner of
the square and then it will also pass
through the center of the inscribed
circle o
if we put these observations together
the intersection point of these two
lines must contain the center o and
therefore this is the center of the
inscribed circle
now let's focus on this quarter circle
the square has a side length of 1 which
means the radius of this quarter circle
is equal to 1.
suppose the inscribed circle has a
radius equal to r
this means the distance between the two
centers is one minus r
we then drop a perpendicular which will
be a radius of the inscribed circle and
this will bisect the side of the square
into two lengths of 0.5
we thus have the following right
triangle and we can use the gogu theorem
0.5 squared plus r squared is equal to
the quantity 1 minus r squared
we'll then do some simplifying algebra
the r squares cancel out and then we can
routinely solve for r
we carefully calculate that r is equal
to
0.375 and that's equal to 3 over 8.
i think this is a fun little problem
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube
as always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]
you